this is a production of cornell
university
yeah thank you tony that's a thank you
for that introduction i appreciate
it um and as as tony said i have uh
been working for the last uh four four
and a half years on a variety of
projects uh all sort of within this
um theme of developing perennial grain
cropping systems
and and even the market opportunities
that that tony briefly mentioned
so a good mix of agronomy and
environmental science
and even economics but we'll get into
that a little bit more
throughout the presentation um so just
to give you a brief outline of what
we'll
discuss today i want to provide a brief
overview of
ecological solutions to agricultural
challenges
to set the stage then introduce you to
the opportunities and challenges of
perennial grain crops which are new
but have a lot of promising aspects in
terms of
sustainability i'll then discuss two of
my research projects
um one where we were looking at
intercropping perennials and annuals
with
medium red clover and another where we
were trying to
mitigate a known yield decline in one of
these perennial crops using strip
tillage
in a more mature stand then i'll just
touch on some conclusions and ways that
we might move forward with perennial
grains research
before opening it up for questions at
the end
so everyone here is is likely pretty
familiar with some of the major
challenges to agricultural
sustainability
particularly from an environmental
perspective which is what we'll largely
focus on here today although my
interests do span into the areas of
social and and economic sustainability
as well
so here on the right we have a figure
that might be familiar to some
um sort of portraying the
uh planetary boundaries in certain areas
so these are
areas where as scientists um there's
some agreement that we are
exceeding the the carrying capacity of
our planet
and some of those areas might be
nutrient pollution usage of fresh water
land system change and all the effects
that has on
biodiversity and ecosystem function
climate change of course
and then some areas that were really not
quite as clear on at this point
um and and what i'll point out here is
anywhere where you're seeing it going
into the red we're
anticipating that we've already exceeded
some of these boundaries and
we need to do something uh immediately
to try to
mitigate um and and find solutions to
these issues
and then i would also note with this uh
diagram in particular anywhere that has
this sort of speckling
is um sort of the estimate of how much
agriculture
contributes to these problems so you can
see especially in the areas that are
outside in the in the red zone
um agriculture is having quite a large
effect on
uh ecosystems and and the sustainability
of our planet
and so to just discuss a few of those uh
our current industrialized agriculture
um has many issues of soil loss and
degradation over time
water and air pollution due to nutrient
runoff
and greenhouse gas emissions uh as i
mentioned land use change so
deforestation and
the the shifting agriculture when we do
run into issues of soil degradation
for example a high reliance on
synthetic fertilizers pesticides and
fossil fuels which
over the long term will not be
sustainable as those resources become
more
limited and as things like
pesticide resistance develop further
fresh water availability in some areas
of the world is becoming a challenge to
agriculture
and then uh sort of that overall
encompassing threat of climate change
and how we might adapt our systems to
still be productive
um but also resilient uh in the face of
climate change
and then uh sort of i've put in this bar
to sort of separate
uh some of the areas that we think that
perennial grains might contribute
versus some other things like food
security and
other social and economic issues which
are heavily entwined in these issues but
might not be solved by simply uh growing
a crop that has some
uh different characteristics
and so uh in particular with food
security i'll highlight that there
because
as i'll mention in the future in a few
slides perennial grains currently do
yield less
food grain than uh comparable annuals
and so that is one of the drawbacks
currently and it's something that
um is informing a lot of the research
that we're trying to do to both
increase those yields but also think
about how we might balance the
the contributions of food
versus other services environmental or
other ways we can use the crop so
broadly um has been suggested that to
counteract some of these threats to
agricultural sustainability
uh we might be able to restore ecosystem
services to cropland so the
uh the concept of ecosystem services
which really became popular after the
millennium ecosystem
assessment uh back in 2005 um
really focuses on the the things other
than material goods
that we can well including material
goods but other
materials and other services we can get
from our ecosystems
the the many ways that that human
society is supported by the natural
world
so uh in this in these panels we can
sort of think about a couple different
systems so in a natural ecosystem
which is maybe modified by humans but is
not designed for agricultural production
there may be some amount of food and
other
crop available um so you can think about
foraging in these contexts or
or fisheries or things like that um but
uh there's many other services that are
widely available so forest production
uh natural habitat and biodiversity
water uh
air quality but
when we when we change those ecosystems
into an intensively managed crop gland
we can really increase the amount of
food or fiber that we produce from those
systems
but we're losing a lot of those other
services
by simplifying the system by going down
to monocultures heavily managed
relying on external inputs as i
mentioned earlier
and in some cases uh you can see these
bubbles are small so
suggesting that there might be services
somewhere some areas there's actually
disservices
so for example water quality might be
impaired
by an intensive cropland if there's a
lot of runoff for nutrient pollution
so really in thinking about
perennial grains they sort of fit into
this area of crop land with restored
ecosystem services where
we're trying to balance that we're still
trying to have a highly productive
agro ecosystem but balance out some of
those
services by diversifying and and
thinking about new ways of managing our
cropland so
we might not get the same uh magnitude
of crop production but where we were
re-um restoring a lot of these other
services
that we can get and uh focusing on
perennial grains um there's a lot of
opportunity at this moment in time
so one thing to think about is that
annual grain crops
are take up about 70 of total global
crop land and account for about 70 of
human food calories if you account for
both
direct consumption and animal feed um
and that's that's costly if we think
from an environmental perspective if we
think about all those
um detriments of intensive cropland
environmentally on the previous slide
but with recent advances in breeding and
biotechnology
perennial grains are really reaching the
point where they could be commercially
viable
and there is a mounting support both
amongst the agricultural community and
consumers
to have a more multi-functional
agriculture that can
provide things other than just uh food
and
calories and then and then finally there
has been some research done
showing evidence for perennial crops as
part of an integrated cropping system
um being more resilient and adaptive to
climate change
and then on top of all of that there's
been a big push both from the
food industry and from research funders
to
to support some of these projects seeing
that these uh
certain perennial grains are right on
the cusp of breaking into the market
um one in particular that i i've worked
with and you'll hear about a lot is
kurza
or a type of intermediate wheatgrass
that has been
put into the first commercial food
product available
uh this long route l from patagonia
provisions
also cascadian farms which is an organic
branch of general mills
has really jumped on to kernsa and is
in r d with breakfast cereals they did a
kickstarter campaign with one of those
cereal bars other products the one of
their goals
like ultimately that they've stated is
to have kurnza
in your your cheerios in your breakfast
cereal at some point in the future so
they they really do see the value of
this um both
to diversify what what they're using in
their
supply chain but also to satisfy certain
commitments they've made
for corporate sustainability
from a from a research funding
perspective you might have seen things
like this cornell chronicle article
about
um a grant that uh that matt
and and other collaborators received
recently um we have here a picture of
uh kerns of bread from wide awake bakery
from one of our research
projects we also recently in the last
couple months
learned of a 10 million usda cap grant
going towards the development of a
current kerns of consortium across many
institutions and so there's a lot of
momentum in this area and so it really
does
um provide an opportunity to make a
difference
uh and just to iterate these are all of
the institutions uh
in that in at least in 2018 we're
working on perennial grain development
um and so here we are in in cornell
so to get in to a little bit more detail
about why perennial grains have all
these environmental benefits um
one thing to to note is the having crops
in the ground year round
and and many of these perennials have
more extensive root systems than annuals
to aid in their persistence can really
contribute to soil health so
here in this diagram thinking about a
potential crop rotation of perennials
with annuals
after several rotations of annual crops
where the soil may have been somewhat
depleted
of organic matter
planting a perennial that over its uh
three maybe five to ten year lifespan
can can contribute to restored soil
health there's
not less tillage during that period
there's more opportunity for
for crop biomass to go back into the
soil
can restore that soil health and lead to
an overall cycling of soil health
throughout time in this in this rotation
another potential uh use is uh in areas
that are particularly prone to erosion
um or areas where um infiltration can be
important so
here you see an annual crop which is
like most of the the water especially in
the
the off season so after the crops been
um harvested and there's just stubble
remaining
there's a lot of potential for soil
detachment and erosion and less
potential for that water to actually
infiltrate back into the ground water
versus a perennial which throughout the
year has a has green biomass growing and
roots deep into the soil there'll be
much less runoff and also the potential
for
higher infiltration and then you can
think a little bit further than just the
perennial crop
on its own here on the left there might
be potential for things like
uh grazing and dual purpose use which
i'll mention
but also the possibility of perennial
polycultures and how
uh diversifying within the field can add
to things like like pollinator
um or even uh other uh wildlife habitat
and so you could see this as a continuum
from the monoculture perennial
uh to maybe a dual crop of a perennial
cereal and a perennial legume
to a completely integrated system that
might have
a variety of different uh plants with
different functionalities
um that gets a little bit more complex
in terms of management
uh so for the focus of where i am at
right now with my research
um we are sort of focusing on this area
here where we can
think about inter-cropping and how
you might have complementarity between a
grass
a grain crop and a nitrogen-fixing
legume and in general
like i said at the beginning things like
low grain yield are a challenge for
perennial systems these
these are new these are new crops and
they don't have the the decade centuries
of uh development of the cropping system
the
investment in infrastructure for the
market
the uh understanding of uh things
like how to establish and uh harvest
the stand so there's there's a lot of
agronomic challenges there's there's
some logistic challenges
there's things like fewer pest
management options without being
able to rotate crops as frequently or
use tillage as a as a tool for weed
management for example
but there are opportunities as i
mentioned having a year ground
year-round ground cover
and those deep root systems can really
help protect the water in the soil
the dual purpose use for grain and
forage production
in the same year utilizing some areas
that might not be suitable for
annual row crafting areas that might be
more sloped or close to
bodies of water and then there's likely
some
some advantages in terms of fewer field
operations so
by planting once and then harvesting
from the same stand for
many years uh you can avoid having that
annual cycle of tillage and replanting
which
for farmers can become a bit of a crunch
during the
that high demand period for for
management on the farm so
there might be some labor there might be
some um energy savings as well
and so if you uh recall back to the the
title of this we're thinking about
perennial grains
through a systems ecology perspective so
i created this uh systems diagram
very early on in my time at cornell just
to help me conceptualize the system and
you could if you took a very close look
there's probably a lot of things that
are missing here
you add too many linkages between things
it starts to look like a pile of
spaghetti
but uh basically the point is that um
with
within the system there's there's the
the crop field itself there's plants
there's soil
there's other organisms there's all of
the assets owned by the farmer that go
into planting harvesting
processing um the the crop but then
there's all these external
inputs some of which are purchased and
some of which are natural
and so the balance between what's
natural
and renewable uh input uh
can uh be a trade-off with some of these
other purchased inputs and
uh the system can be supported by
interactions within the system
to make some of these external things
more or less important in the overall
production system so
you could think of things like
external soil amendments being added to
improve the fertility of the soil but if
the the soil
um ecosystem is healthy enough then
there might be less need for those so
there's a lot going on here but it's
it's really thinking about how the
system as a whole
all the pieces interact to make
something that's that's greater than
each of those individual parts
and so we don't really want to focus in
just on the the crop
plants and and how we can get the most
productivity out of them
we also need to think about all these
other aspects and so here i've
highlighted some areas that
i've really focused on with my phd
research
thinking about soil health and how
perennials
might be different than annuals in that
respect how
the non-crop plants weeds might
interact with the the crop plants or you
could even think of non-crop plants as
things like a forage legume which may
not be providing
a grain yield but is is also
contributing to the overall system
obviously we are looking at the
productivity of the crop
and then the economic side of things and
how a perennial at this point in its
development
might uh be economically viable for for
a farmer
and so i've conducted uh
probably too many research projects i i
sort of
commit to a lot of things but here i
just highlight
some of the things we've been looking at
to try to address some of these
challenges try to provide answers and
just to better understand the system so
these first two are the ones that i'll
focus on here today intercropping with
medium red clover and strip tillage
renovation we've also tried
intercropping with field peas
thinking about weed management after
harvest during that regrowth period in
the fall
trying to figure out which herbicides
might be
good for use in weed management for
perennial grains
also pathogens and some some more
physiological work some
some more soil work and even as as tonya
mentioned
the work with miguel gomez and others in
the dyson school as well as
collaborations with
folks at wide awake bakery to understand
what consumers would be willing to pay
for
a perennial grain product and whether
they
would be willing to perhaps pay more for
something that has
all these environmental benefits and so
i just highlight here all of our some of
our external collaborators
while everything up here has been really
uh within cornell but really
also supported by so many members of the
the tommaso and ryan labs that i'll
acknowledge at the end as well
and so as i said we'll be focusing on
these two for the purposes of getting
through the next
30 minutes um and so
here i'll introduce you to the two
perennial grain crops that we've we
focused on
on the left is kurza intermediate wheat
grass or thino pyramin intermedium which
is a wild perennial grass that for the
last 40 years
has been under domestication for grain
production so
that started it the rhode island student
in pennsylvania
eventually moved to the land institute
in salina kansas and really over the
last five years or so
has been one of the main perennial crops
that people are interested in for
the reasons i pointed out earlier
interest from the food industry there's
been
a lot of momentum built up behind this
crop it does seem to be one of the more
developed
from a cultivar perspective and then on
the right we have ace one
perennial cereal rye which i contrast
with
kunza as an annual grain crop that has
been perennialized via hybridization so
by crossing your cereal rice cayley
cereal with
mountain rye they are hoping to
introduce some of those perennial genes
but maintain many of the characteristics
of an annual grain crop
so things like free threshability
synchronous maturity large seed size
some of those actually are are really
what the breeders are focusing on in
kernsis so
as the domestication process goes along
you're trying to
make the um the small seed of a wild
grass into something that
looks like a rye or a wheat
and so i'll i'll contrast these in how
they've been developed uh from a
cultivar perspective but
that all that contrast also does play
out in how they perform in the field
uh which we'll see in a few slides
and so for the first research experiment
that i conducted
intercropping perennials with annuals
with clover
we started this one really thinking from
that system's perspective with five
broad research objectives
uh we did want to understand uh how much
grain and crop biomass would be produced
by the perennials
in comparison with annuals uh we wanted
to understand the weed community better
and identify weeds that might be
problematic in these perennial systems
so we could
later target our management we wanted to
look at soil health as i said
and then two that are grayed out here
are are the economic piece which i won't
talk about today
um and and trying to see what would uh a
consumer need to pay for a perennial
grain in order for it to break even
from an economic perspective with
something like a wheat
and then the evaluating certain
indicators of overwhelm
overall system sustainability so
not necessarily life cycle analysis but
if you're familiar with that concept
things of that nature and seeing how
they might compare
um broadly so
as i said all of those things we're
really looking at with this single field
experiment
the experimental design uh was a
randomized complete block design with
four main plot treatments and those were
the four
grain crops that we grew so kernsa the
intermediate wheatgrass
taste one rye a hard red winter wheat
and then
two varieties of malting barley um which
in our colder new york climate actually
didn't do too well so
eventually we're dropped from the
experiment but i do want to mention them
here especially since they're in
the diagram um and each of these was
grown uh in split plots both
with and without medium red clover so
each of these
um plots in the field had had half of it
grown as a monoculture
uh and then half of it with the medium
red clover frost seeded
in march of each year for for the
annuals and then and cross-feeded
in the first year for the perennials
um so after growing the plants we
sampled crop and weed biomass in uh
at grain maturity for each of the the
species
uh each summer so for wheat and barley
that's earlier in july for
perennial rye that's later in july and
kerns it's actually
the middle of august so that does also
by
adding these to the cropping system
might diversify even the harvest window
um and like i mentioned earlier it takes
some of the burden off of growers that
often are really trying to get
everything in at the same time
but by clipping the biomass and uh
the weeds and and the weeds were sorted
by species we
uh threshed and and behold if necessary
the the
uh the grain crops so dehulling uh
particularly for kurenza which like i
said those characteristics of
domestication it has an adherent hall
which
is a little bit harder to process
and then all of the grain yield
estimates are based on a correction to
13 and a half percent moisture
and i'll just show a few uh photos just
to give you an idea of what these
look like in the field so uh here on the
left uh kerns of intermediate wheatgrass
about two months after planting
and an h1ri which is pretty good i'll
say actually when
i put this into powerpoint and it gives
you those little suggestions for like an
alternative text
uh powerpoint thought this was a train
going down some tracks
so uh basically picking up on the fact
there's not much green material here
early on
and with kernzo that's something we've
learned it's it's slower to establish
but once it gets going it can produce a
lot of biomass but particularly in that
first
fall um it doesn't look like much and
then the next
spring about april when you actually
start to see it fill out
and that poses some challenges for weed
management during that period
and that did play out a little bit going
into the next
spring so you can see the karnza is now
growing pretty tall but
weeds did manage to get in there in the
meantime and and might be uh
competing with the crop uh but while rye
looks uh
really good and and there's very little
weed biomass under there it was able to
to get up uh grow tall quickly and and
really
exclude weeds from the system um but
after harvest in that first years when
we noticed the the real first contrast
between
or this i guess the second contrast
other than establishment between these
two species
uh so kern's up quickly regrew after
harvest and you can see it here
above the clover um
but ace one struggled so it uh after
after harvest the the clover really took
over and seemed to out compete
the the rye in that system and so the
uh story after three years is that with
clover
uh in the kerns of we we might be seeing
a visual difference maybe that it's a
little bit greener maybe some extra
nitrogen there
but both systems are looking pretty
healthy
um in contrast with ace one rye both
with and without clover
where with clover the the ace one rye
was out competed and there's some rye
plants still there but
quite few um and without the clover
all the rye got out competed by other
weeds that came in and there might be
even fewer plants without the clover
so really what happened with ace one
is that it wasn't competitive in that
post-harvest period and that
sort of accumulated over time and so we
we didn't do any weed management in
these systems we're
trying to understand some of these
factors being the first time we've grown
them
but that does seem to be a critical
period for weed control and something
that in other experiments has been shown
to help with the persistence
and productivity of the ace one going
into a second or third year
and so for these these first two
objectives of looking at grain yields
and
weed communities i'll just go into some
of the data
with our data analysis uh we only i'm
only reporting kurza and we
here um for the reasons we just saw with
the ace one there really wasn't much to
speak of
uh into the third year and actually not
not that much in the second year either
and with the winter kill of the malting
barley we had dropped that from the
experiment
but we did look at crop and forage
yields and we biomass for the kerns
and wheat analyzed it with mixed effects
anova
we had to log transform the data due to
skewness
and had crop species intercropping and
near as fixed effects so you'll be
seeing
similar models for all of these
treatments
throughout the the following slides um
and uh we'll get to weed communities
eventually where we have
an ordination uh to visualize it and
then permanova and indicator species
analysis to look at what's
going on in more detail in those systems
so for grain yield uh the main takeaways
here there was a significant crop
difference between crops
and there was a significant effect by
year with an interaction between the two
there was no effect of the clover
intercrop on
grain yield however and so really the
story is
with kernsa it was lower than the wheat
in that first year but then declined
into the second year and rebounded
slightly into the third year
whereas wheat had statistically similar
yields throughout all three years there
might be a slight
decline over time but nothing
significant there
and so um really this this
this deep the the initially lower grain
yields followed by a decline is a major
issue for kurza
um and and something that we'll even
talk about a little bit in the second
experiment to address that
uh with forage yields they were
initially similar but
kernsa biomass tended to increase over
time
while wheat biomass decreased and so
that is one area of opportunity for the
perennial grains and used as a dual
purpose
dual purpose grain and forage crop where
a grower might be able to balance out
the low grain yields with high forage
production if they're able to
use that in the system and i will say as
the perennials stay greener for longer
into the year
through the year they they do make a
much higher quality forage than
something like wheat straw which you
could also
harvest from a wheat field but not as
valuable
oh and i will say here there was a
significant effect of inner crop and so
adding clover to the system increased
total forage production
and uh we didn't analyze a forage
quality but you could
the the higher protein of the forage
of a clover forage might have increased
quality as well
and then when we look at weeds um really
the um story is that the there was a
difference by species as we saw with the
slow establishment of kernsa
um there were weeds early on and those
tended to
stay in the system throughout the three
years
there was again a significant effect by
year
and an interaction there i will also say
that
the clover did have a significant weed
suppressive effect
so you can see that there's quite a lot
lower
weeds in the clover plots across all the
systems
but a wheat the weeds increased over
time so a difference between
the perennial and the annual system
there's actually been other studies with
kern zone where maybe they got
established a little bit better where
weeds are suppressed by the currency
itself over time so that's not something
we saw here but it is
another potential benefit of a perennial
system that's highly competitive and
persistent
and then we when we took a closer look
at the the weed communities
um by species here we we have an
ordination so
the axes are not that meaningful really
what we're looking at these centroids
are sort of the central tendency of
different treatments
where the closer together points are on
the on the plot the more similar they
are in their weed communities
and so all of the green is the kurza
both with and without clover
and then the the brown or tan is
the wheat and so even here on this
initial plot you can sort of
see some clustering in certain areas but
when we look at this
by year we see um a definite shift in
the weed communities over
time so from 2017 uh capernaum with and
without clover both shifted along this
x-axis to the right maybe in
in slightly different directions
and then we also see with with wheat um
a shift
initially to the right but then sort of
back again
towards the left so um this is this is
telling us that there
are there is divergence between the
communities of weeds we're seeing in
these systems
and to confirm that with the permanova
which is really the statistical test
here
we saw significant species and inner
crop effects
and year effects with again this this
strong
interaction between year and crop
basically the the perennial changing
over time while the annual sort of
stayed the same maybe changed and back
and and so looking at each year
individually we see that the clover in a
crop had the strongest effect in that
second year
and i believe that's because that's when
um
the the kernzo was really um coming into
its own and then by the third year that
kerns it was starting to outcompete the
clover even
when we look at indicator species so so
what this indicates is that
uh each time there's a significant uh
p-value for a species it means that that
species is particularly prevalent
um on plots of that type and so we can
interpret this by looking uh
in 2017 with kurza and no clover a
winter annual shepherd's purse was
really indicative of that cropping
system
while um wood sorrel was particularly
indicative of the wheat no clover
cropping system
and so we didn't have any significant
indicators in 2018 with this data
um but uh by 2019 we are
starting to again see that clear
separation in in the systems
so uh with the kearns and no clover we
are seeing a lot of perennials some uh
timothy and uh rough stock bluegrass
perennial grasses and then
uh canada goldenrod and dandelion
broadly perennials
with wheat and clover we were seeing a
um a perennial sedge
yellow nuts edge that was able to
compete through that clover and come up
in that system
and wasn't really seen in any of the
other systems and then wheat no clover
we're seeing start to see a broad
variety of annuals very common animals
yellow foxtail
ragweed and a couple of polygams
and so here one thing you'll notice is
that with with clover there weren't any
significant indicators because the
clover was suppressing a lot of the weed
species and sort of evening things out
broadly but without clover we're
starting to really see that divergence
between a perennial and an annual
weed community
moving on to soil health um sampling
here was
done each year including a baseline
collection
soon after planting in 2016. after that
we always sampled
after harvest before replanting so
before the annual plots were re-tilled
we collected samples with golf whole
course the relatively large diameter
and to a relatively shallow depth
and then we analyzed uh bulk density in
the lab and then sent
to the soil health lab for wet aggregate
stability soil respiration and active
carbon and really
i'll just say this up front there there
wasn't a lot of variation between the
systems
over time i'm here with bulk density
we're seeing a slight effect
uh by year and an interaction by year in
species so
so with wheat in uh one year it might
have been a little bit of higher than
wheat in a different year
but nothing too dramatic with wet
aggregate stability it was only a year
effect
where we sort of saw a bump up and then
down
and again with soil respiration there
was simply a year effect
this might be due to different
environmental conditions and year and
2018 in particular was very dry
so not a lot to read into these with
active carbon we did
see a very close significant
crop species effect and so here
there was slightly higher active carbon
in wheat than kernsa
across the three years when everything
was pooled and so that's a little bit
perplexing
i haven't really thought about it too
much if anyone has any thoughts on why
that might be occurring
my initial thoughts may be just because
we were sampling so shallowly
while the kerns of roots are going
deeper there could be something
going on there but not not what we
expected to see really with the soil
health at all not much of an effect
and so the takeaways from this first
experiment are that
uh the kernzo was persistent and
produced more total biomass than annual
crops but lower grain yields over time
ace one struggled overall and failed
completely by the third year
we did see that divergence in the weed
communities and clover had a strong
effect on suppressing weeds
um perennial grass weeds like rough
stock bluegrass and timothy probably
are have the highest likelihood of
becoming weed management challenges in
kenza
particularly because of uh there might
be few selective herbicides that are
able to control those especially after
a uh kerns of stand has been established
so
that once you get that stand going and
you don't really want to till it up and
replant it
there there might be some challenges in
getting some weeds out of there if they
if they do establish a foothold
and finally soil health was had stronger
effects by year than by crop species or
intercropping treatments
so i would focus in here on this first
point
about lower grain yields that decline
over time because that really informed
this second
experiment uh using strip tillage to
renovate mature kernel stands
um this decline is not unique to our
experiment
it's been documented across basically
every research project
that's looked at kerns over time and
this is not associated with plant
mortality as tiller counts
and total biomass productivity are
stable or increase over time which is
something we have also observed
so with that in mind we thought about
uh what might be causing that and it
seems like maybe the kernel itself was
competing
uh too strongly with itself and so
we thought that maybe using some
disturbance in that system
might give it a chance to regrow
and and produce more seed rather than
vegetative biomass
so we tried two timings fall and spring
and wanted to look at closely at
components of yield to see
what the response to this disturbance
might be
so really this was just a deep ripping
with a with a deep shank on the
no-till planter disturbing in pretty
narrow strips and a
relatively low intensity disturbance
all things considered compared to other
things that people have tried with kerns
at least
this was a simpler experiment with just
three treatments per block
of the fall the spring and then the
control treatments
and um this was done in a fourth year
kern's a stand so it had been it had
been in the ground had harvested three
times
um it had been uh planted in 2014
fertilized every year only one
application of herbicide due to
growing canada thistle issue
and then with the zone builder
went in after that third harvest both in
october and then the next april
uh that that following august at the
fourth grain harvest we did similar
quadrat sampling as to the first
experiment but here we also sampled
20 spikes from each sample that were
fresh by hand to count spikeless florics
and seeds per spike
everything else was also threshed to you
to estimate total grain yield
and we used a similar mixed effect model
with only tillage as a fixed effect here
so here this photo i like it's hard to
see anything which is actually
uh we almost didn't harvest this
experiment at all because it didn't seem
like anything different was going on in
the treatment
but but chris took this photo on top of
the combine because
um it seemed like there might have been
something going on here in this fall
treatment uh maybe a slightly uh higher
density of seed heads
while not much visually different
between spring control but
you couldn't really see that until you
got up high on the combine
but it really did um play out to be an
interesting effect in the end so
um first when we looked at the the
components of yield
there was really strong consistency for
spikelet count
for floret count for seed count
and even for a thousand kernel weights
so those uh within spike
components of yield we're not changing
amongst any of these treatments
but when we look at the the total
biomass
that was produced so that all of the
vegetative and above ground biomass
in these plots there was no difference
between the control and the fall
treatment there was a decrease from that
spring treatment so maybe the
disturbance there is a little too strong
or too soon close
to tillering
total tiller density was lower in both
the fall and the spring treatment so
these are these are all stems in the
plots
but when we look at reproductive tiller
density so those tillers that produce
seed heads
we see a significant increase in the
number of fertile tillers in a fall
tilled plot
and this leads to about a 60 increase in
overall grain yield which is really
outstanding is really what we're looking
for in using this management practice
and also in harvest index so we had a
an increase in grain and a decrease in
or a slight decrease in total biomass
and and so that harvest index is
something we're
really interested in at that point so
uh that was quick but really the
takeaway here is that
this fall tillage disturbance did
increase grain yield by a large amount
at that following harvest this was done
in the fourth year
um so by then the yield had declined
substantially and so the
the total grain uh production was still
much lower than you would get from an
annual um but it does
provide insight into what might be going
on in the field
basically that our assumptions of
intra-specific competition
uh is likely what's causing this this
change in in the plant's reproductive
output over time with spring tillage it
did reduce stand density and biomass but
if you i i didn't mention this on this
the data slide but it did not impact
granules so the spring tillage
um didn't actually decrease yield in
that year and so you could think maybe
in the future year that that would have
a similar increase in effect giving it
time to regrow
and then really for the future we would
want to examine even close
more closely the timing the intensity
and even the type of disturbance so here
we use
strip tillage and i know some of our
collaborators in the midwest have done
things like grazing
or using strip applied herbicides but
there could be even broader things to
think about so like crop residue burning
and whether that stimulates
tiller development anything of that
nature
and so really to wrap it up with
hopefully a few minutes for questions
um there's a lot of things uh
going on in these perennial systems and
the complexity is
is higher for both us as researchers
there's a lot more
things we are trying to figure out and
manage um here
especially with the the novelty of these
systems like managing weed crop
at different periods during
establishment during the post-harvest
period during
subsequent years and that crop crop
competition with the perennial
that's vigorous in growing vegetative
biomass but might need to be stimulated
in some way
to maintain its seed production over
time
but the complexity of managing something
for production of both grain and forage
as well so
how do you balance that are there ways
that managing
maybe mowing at different points during
the year which is something we've looked
at a little bit
might increase your forage productivity
but might decrease your grain yield is
there a trade-off there
and how does that work out economically
and then um
to the point we saw that over a
three-year period
um there wasn't a strong effect on soil
health and there might even be um
wheat outperforming uh kerns and maybe
just because of wheat uh growing more
vigorously
over that that period um but
uh restore basically the takeaway there
is restoring ecosystem service is not as
simple as just growing a new crop
that these crops may have a lot of
benefits but they also need to be
integrated into a system
across many spatial and temporal scales
with
interacting with many other components
and and how you manage that is all
tied up into what we actually um can
obtain from those systems both in terms
of
uh material goods and other services um
and
there's there's a lot of room for
improvement of these parental cropping
systems
um i don't breed but the breeders are
still working on them and so
we'll be seeing improvement in their
performance over time um and
like these projects that that i've been
working on the agronomic management will
also have a significant impact on that
so
well i would say that these might not be
ready to
to put in the ground everywhere right
now uh this is the promising
uh area of research and uh hopefully
within the next couple decades we'll be
we'll be seeing currency in our cheerios
and lastly just acknowledging everyone
um i have
pictures of all of the the technicians
and uh
and field uh undergrad assistants that
have helped over time
uh in particular uh tessandra chris and
scott
uh who have done just so much you know
that long list of projects i've worked
on wouldn't be possible without all the
contributions all these folks
my committee of course and and all the
the lab mates and fellow grad
students that i've worked with over the
years and then
all my external collaborators starting
with the farmers we've got a great board
of advisors
the the folks at uh wide awake bakery
and farmer ground flour on some of the
economic side of things
and then uh external collaborators other
institutions working also on perennial
brains
and then uh finally just these uh
funders that have have so
graciously allowed me to do this work
and
took a little bit longer than i thought
but hopefully we have a cup time for low
questions i'm willing to stick around a
little while
if people want to ask me some stuff as
well
great thanks eugene that was that's
really a nice overview of
of the various projects you've been
working on related to perennial grain so
let's open it up for
for questions i know we have you know a
little bit of time but
go ahead unmute yourself or
yeah go ahead david yeah
very interesting eugene i really learned
a lot
what is kind of the uh upper limit of
where these yields could be
due to people think i mean if you take a
a typical wheat yield
let's say six tons or you know you
you're up in that four or five six tons
or whatever
where do people think these could
possibly get to if everything was right
yeah well so it's a bit of a tricky
question
due to just the time um
aspect of it or like do you account that
accumulatively over time and how does
that
that trade off um but um
currently i mean i don't want to put
hard numbers on it but you might expect
like
in the first year maybe 25 of a
comparable wheat like we saw in that one
experiment
and after that we did see that sharp
decline
there was a actually there was a session
at tri-societies last week on this where
there's sort of a bit of a debate
between one of the main breeders of
kurnsah and then someone who's done a
lot more
work in more like perennial forages and
you know there are life history
trade-offs so
in order for a perennial to to survive
over winter produce new stems the
following year
it needs to dedicate energy to that and
an annual is really putting all of its
energy into creating that seed then
dies we harvest it and we move on so
there there might be a substantial trade
off there we don't know
uh how close we could get to an annual
just based on that but
there's also the the balance of
photosynthetic
production over the the full course of
the year so with a perennial like kernsa
once it's established the following year
it's going to be
starting growing much sooner than a
spring wheat because
it's there as soon as the weather gets
warm enough whereas the farmer might
have to wait for
things to dry down and and get the seed
in
um and it's there throughout the the
fall as well so the the total amount of
photo
uh photosynthetic photosynthetic
radiation that's hitting that plant over
the the course of the year will be
higher than the annual
yeah and so that might balance out some
of these these trade-offs and
um i think there's been studies done for
for um perennial bio
um biomass feedstocks like miss campus
that show that
their total net primary productivity is
going to be much higher
due to the the higher amount of sunlight
they can take in over the course of the
year
whether we can get the plants to to put
more of that towards seed production
is the challenge and how how that
balances out with the management of the
system as a whole
is where we would we would need to
to that's where we are moving forward i
guess i was just kind of curious
i know all those other benefits you you
laid that out very nicely yeah
of the complexity and how it might use
in a system i understand all that
it's just kind of wondering you know if
you were aiming for grain yield how high
did the breeders think
could it end up being 50 of what we
would otherwise would expect or would it
be
because you had very low yields um you
know 250
kilograms rectangle seed and you know
i'm not criticizing i'm just kind of
curious
where the community thinks this is could
end up going so that was my question
about the
seed yeah yeah it's hard to speculate i
guess
i will say i mean one thing i didn't
mention is that i i've been working with
with these
like kerza for example for five years
and when we planted that first
experiment in 2016
it was cycle three uh breeding from the
land institute
they're not on cycle eight and i can say
just by going out to kansas for
conferences and stuff that the
the difference in the plants in cycle
eight versus cycle three is just
tremendous
in both the size of the inflorescences
the number of
um spikelets and and like all those
components yields which i didn't find
any difference in
in my experiment those over breeding
cycles are increasing
so um there's there's going to be a lot
of advancement in that area but
yeah and in terms of what those those
newer cycles would produce in a you know
like um
actual farm field at this point i'm not
sure
thanks very clear
hi thanks eugene
very nice clear presentation i'm
wondering sort of from the systems
perspective
whether you have thought about
comparing um
with maybe sort of an optimized
spatially optimized system using current
more commercial cultivars so i'm
thinking
maybe strip cropping with corn grain and
alfalfa right so you'd be getting forage
production
you're getting grain production you're
getting perennials on
half the land all the time
and i guess what i'm getting at here is
it seems to me that by
by doing some of that kind of practical
optimization
spatially you might get many of the
benefits that you're aiming to get
uh by combining
[Music]
you know trying to combine all the
functions in into one
one patch of land
yeah though i think that's a great idea
i know there's there's a lot of folks
that have done that type of work and
have looked at different cropping
systems um
sort of layouts and and i mean even in
um even in like matt's lab with with
looking at
different um ways of using cover crops
right there's there's different ways to
try to
to put different functions back into the
agro ecosystem and and i'm not saying
here that
perennial grains are the only way to do
that i just um i think that it's a
it's it's promising because it of like
at that that one point at the beginning
annual grains make up so much of the
cropland
uh that we have and and if we're ever
gonna we
basically we need to do something there
right and um
if we could somehow get perennial grains
to the point where they're just
as to go to sort of david's point um
they're just as productive
in grain as as the annual and um
also producing forage and providing
these other environmental services it
seems like that has
um that that's sort of like um a
paradigm shift and
um yeah i i completely agree there's
lots of
lots of ways to think about this like
the cropping systems we use and how we
might innovate on them um
i'm sorry does that sort of like address
that point i guess
yeah that's fine i mean i i appreciate
all the information it's it's i guess i
would
maybe clarify what i was just trying to
get at is
is you know when we're comparing kind of
alternative or
what we hope are improved practices i
guess i would just encourage
comparing that to you know kind of the
top of the line
management practice for current
production systems
which might involve in some places
you know strips of perennials and
annuals for instance if there's an
erosion issue that kind of thing so it's
more just
sort of thinking about what the baseline
is that we compare
you know uh compared to
yeah that's not no okay that does help
clarify things a little bit
yeah i appreciate that and i i would say
that that moving forward i think that
that's an excellent
place to to think um at the start of
this we we really didn't know what we
were working with
um and i think we just to explain our
thought process
is to try to keep things simple and um
maybe maybe not be thinking so far down
the road of like what is the most
productive way to grow these because we
didn't really know but also
just trying to to think of of
as our first baseline it's like well if
we have an annual or perennial like what
are what are the differences what are
what's still or what's different and
from moving from there
to our next steps of trying to optimize
that and tweak it further and what's
your next question
that's revealed by some of those those
early
results i guess um but
yeah that and i mean i could probably
talk for a long time about what i think
we could do going forward
um but yeah
eugene this is andy i wonder if maybe
there's a follow-up to that
you could talk a little bit about the
ecosystem services gains that you
anticipate to be associated with the
perennial system
you did a lot of work on soil health
assessment
and there may be some reasons why you
didn't see the difference based on the
soil
sampling depth but i'm curious if you
think about
quantifying ecosystem services gains
moving forward from these systems
what would you look at and what kind of
benefits do you think you
you'd um see if you expanded the kind of
quantification that you
that you do yeah well
so well what i'll say is is
is just based on what some of my
collaborators have done
um they're they're seeing a lot of
benefits in area where there might be
nitrate leashing
so kern's a with those deep roots is
able to
like really prevent nitrate from getting
down on the water table
there have been um really good
projects that have shown soil health
benefits um
over time maybe we didn't have the
length of time necessary or maybe like
you said sampling depth is an issue
um i
didn't know about stratified send about
centimeters and still processing some of
that data to see if there
anything going on at depth there um
i know that there's folks in kansas
doing things um
with like uh gas exchange and trying to
better understand uh like air uh quality
and and greenhouse gas emissions and
things from the system doing like sort
of the net
balance of stuff in and out um
so i and then i mean i guess wildlife
and
uh some some work with uh ducks
unlimited
that um and the nrcs the um
in sort of like conservation uh
easements
and the possibility of even like having
a conservationist
that you could harvest for a grain um if
it's um
providing so i guess this is a policy
question and i'm not
i don't want to go too far down that
road but like thinking about it like
if if the the plan itself is providing
the
the benefits to the system that you want
from a conservation easement in terms of
providing wildlife habitat protecting
water um
then why not harvest it if that's not
gonna do any damage
right so um that's that's just another
way of thinking about integrating it
into a system and thinking beyond like
current boundaries
to how that might um might fit in
somewhere else
so i i would say if my personal next
steps forward one thing that i've really
started to focus on more
is just weed management obviously i'm in
tony's lab so that's something we focus
on a lot but
um really like we saw from that first
experiment like
what if we had um been able to manage
weeds and kerns in that first year and
prevented them from getting that
foothold that might have persisted
throughout the whole experiment
and the same thing with the rye if he
had been able to maintain those those
decent rye yields from the first year
through three years
then that's a really promising outcome
um so
over the past two years or so we've been
doing some um
some competition studies and also like i
i mentioned herbicide screenings
to try to so i think in order to get any
services out of the system no matter
what they end up being
we need to have a productive and
effective system in general so that
includes all of these aspects and so
that's actually one of the reasons why
it's so great to have such a great team
of collaborators both here at cornell
and at other places is that
different people are looking at
different aspects of it and
and we come together and and try to
figure out um
how to handle it all together
i know we're getting past time so if
some people need need to leave eugene if
folks have other questions anybody a
burning question
that you'd like to ask eugene
[Music]
eugene one quick question from me was uh
what do we know from the consumer side
of things are folks willing to pay a
little more
uh what are you kind of getting from
from those results
yeah we're working on that paper um with
miguel
gomez and dyson and um
so that we did we did so what we did
last fall uh fall 2019
was a consumer preference testing so
basically brought in a bunch of
uh people into a computer lab
gave them kerns of bread and then other
breads
um also very nice breads made by wide
awake bakery
and asked them what how what they liked
about the
sort of like the taste and other
culinary qualities of the breads
and also what they would be willing to
pay both
with only the taste and once we provided
them with information about the
environmental
potential environmental benefits of the
crops of the crops that were used to
create the bread so
we had um kurnza at different variety
levels of flower incorporation and then
we had
spelt as a as a comparison of sort of an
interesting but
um maybe not as ecologically beneficial
grain
um and so the re the real me the
the high level takeaways there that
people did not like the taste of turns
of bread as much
and this is in a general consumer pool
and um
it's it's more brandy it might have a
bit more of a grassy flavor
or sort of like um nutty flavor
so some people like i love it i think
it's great i've eaten a lot of kurenza
but um for the general consumer market
maybe not their taste but when you do
give them that environmental information
they were willing to pay more
for for the kurza and that's both with
and without um
tasting and so that's that's promising
how much more i think was maybe like
five percent so with the yields
how low they are you would still need to
um the prop production cost
uh trade-off that's something i'm
working on in terms of the break-even
analysis
would need to be fairly high if you're
only getting a five percent price
premium
um at the market but um
it is showing that there is some um
potential for for um
almost thinking of it like a payment for
services if it's marketed right to
maybe the right audience um it could it
could have that
benefit as well okay
michael i see you have a chat question
do you want to unmute and just ask it or
would you like me to read it off maybe
you could just ask
sure hi thank you very much um um
maybe this is a little apropos uh peter
woodbury's question
um i think of this as being part of a
a step towards these more complex
polycultures and i'm curious i mean
that's sort of the original attention
behind the
programs at the land institute etc i'm
curious what are
some of the more critical bottlenecks
that resolving the
resolving those would get us closer to
the polyculture idea
so i i think that there's a couple of
things
um from from an ecological perspective
we just need to do more work on on
finding the right mixes
and and the right sort of um both
spatial
and temporal um
distributions like how you combine that
so you can think of a
polyculture in the field all at the same
time
or over time uh well that's more of a
rotation but
but in in thinking about like the large
scale effect
yeah so basically figuring out which
plants work well together and
and how they work together and then the
the big challenge after that is is how
do
like i think harvesting is particularly
challenging especially if you're trying
to get
um like multiple um like if you're
like we did one experiment with harvest
with putting perennial grains and then
field peas together and tried to harvest
both of them together
and it was just really difficult just
the differences in sort of like the
maturity
timing and the the height of the things
you're trying to harvest
and and having the right machinery to do
that
um so i i think even just that step
of once you have a polyculture that
where the plants actually get along
is is having a a system that supports
that in terms of the
like having machinery i mean
even even with kernels by itself we've
struggled so much
with just getting it combined and then
processed
um and and we're using stuff that's
designed for wheat
right and kerns is not wheat but but
that's what's available
to growers and and even to us as
researchers so so i think that's a big
barrier
i think um i think on one of my takeaway
slides the complexity is a big barrier
and so that's more of on an adoption
side of things
that um i think part of the reason that
that growers do things well that they do
is because
it it it fits within their their job
as a farmer and like they have
limitations in terms of
um their their labor their
machinery their their land and their
time
and get the more complex the system is
the more management it's going to take
and and that
would require more people doing it or
more time
uh in general and and again with like
the machinery aspect if you do need
specialized machinery to harvest from
one of these systems in
an efficient manner then you're asking
the farmer to go buy another piece of
equipment which is
can be incredibly costly so um
like the simplification of agricultural
systems is really
at multiple levels to um
to i mean it enables us to grow a lot on
a lot of acres in using a lot of the
same
machinery and a lot of the same methods
and once you step outside of that
it just be like it's the extra effort to
step outside of that is
is a little bit much for a lot of folks
yeah thank you great i know we're way
past time
so um i would encourage anybody who's
got some additional questions maybe to
reach out to
to eugene directly otherwise eugene
thanks for those really nice talk
covering a lot of
and there's a lot more behind all of
that obviously so thanks again to all of
you who hung
in there
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu